IN THE LAST THREE HOURS AND
15 MINUTES, YES.
>> Bret: A WHILE BACK.
PETER, THANK YOU.
THERE ARE SERIOUS QUESTIONS IF
NANCY PELOSI BACK IN D.C. WILL
BE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE WHEN
DEMOCRATS TAKE OVER THE CHAMBER
NEXT YEAR.
PELOSI DOES NOT YET HAVE A
VISIBLE CHALLENGER.
MOST EXPECT HER TO GET THE
GLOBAL WERE GOOD.
SHE HAS A GROUP OF DEMOCRATS
FIRMLY AGAINST HER RETURN TO THE
TOP SPOT.
CHIEF CORRESPONDENT MIKE EMANUEL
LOOKS AT BOTH SIDES TO THAT FROM
CAPITOL HILL.
>> I INTEND TO WIN MAKE THE
SPEAKERSHIP WITH DEMOCRATIC
VOTES.
>> THERE ARE SIGNS IT WILL BE
EASY.
FOX HAS CONFIRMED THAT 70
DEMOCRATS, SOME INCUMBENTS, SOME
NEWLY ELECTED, SIGNED ALL THE
LETTER THAT THEY WILL NOT ACCEPT
PELOSI.
SHE NOTED THAT 14 WERE MEN.
>> WE GOT SUPPORT FROM -- AND
THE WOMEN WHO ARE NEW MEMBERS IN
OUR CAUCUS, SO I GET THE UPSIDE,
I THINK, OF BEING A WOMAN.
YOU HAVE TO ASK THEM.
IF, IN FACT, THERE IS ANY OF MY
SUBSIDY IN IT, IT'S THEIR
PROBLEM.
NOT MINE.
>> MARCIA FUDGE WAS OPENLY SAID
SHE'S RUNNING FOR SPEAKER TOO.
>> SHE'S THE KIND OF NEW LEADER
WE NEED IN THIS PARTY.
SHE'S INCREDIBLE.
THAT'S THE KIND OF LEADER I WANT
TO SEE.
>> NEW YORK REPUBLICAN TOM REED
CONSIDERING BACKING PELOSI IF
SHE ENDORSES CHANGES IN RULES
THAT -- IF PELOSI FINDS A WAY TO
ROUND UP THE VOTES, COLLEAGUES
NOTES SHE HAS THE CHALLENGE OF
LEADING A SPIRITED GROUP OF
FRESHMEN.
>> WE'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE PRACTICES IN PLACE IN THE
CAUCUS THAT THEIR VOICES ARE
HEARD.
>> THEY ARE VOCAL.
CONGRESSMAN ELECT ALEXANDRA
BECAUSE HER COURT HAS PELOSI'S
OFFICE ON HER FIRST DAY OF
ORIENTATION.
SHE'S PUSHING FOR A GREEN NEW
DEAL AND WAS TO WORK TOWARDS THE
GOAL OF 100% RENEWABLE ENERGY.
OTHER DEMOCRATS ARE PUSHING FOR
MEDICARE FOR ALL, WHICH COULD
CAUSE 34 OVER $.6 TRILLION OF
YEARS ACCORDING TO A GEORGE
MASON UNIVERSITY STUDY.
THERE ARE THOSE, INCLUDING A
LIKELY CHAIR WHO CALLS FOR
IMPEACHING PRESIDENT TRUMP.
A NEW MEMBER OF THE HOUSE G.O.P.
LEADERSHIP SAYS KEEPING
DEMOCRATS MCCRIGHT IS NOT GOING
TO BE EASY.
>> I'M SURE MINORITY LEADER
PELOSI LIKES THE NEW ENERGY
THAT'S COMING IN.
THE PROBLEM IS MOST OF THAT MOST
OF THOSE INCOMING DEMOCRATS ARE
SOCIALIST.
THAT'S NOT A RECIPE FOR SUCCESS.
>> THE
>> SOME AFRICAN-AMERICAN MEMBERS
ARE TAKING OFFENSE, NOTING THAT
NO ONE HAS OFFICIALLY STEPPED UP
THE CHALLENGE PELOSI OR WITH